no es una sorpresa que la negociación se
haya estancado justo ahora que se habla
de lo fundamental ya se ha venido
negociando durante meses y es que
ninguna de las dos partes quiere ceder
en lo que ha llamado sus líneas rojas
como los derechos pesqueros en esta
conversación los dos líderes de londres
y de bruselas se espera que la política
la voluntad política se imponga sobre
las diferencias pero lo cierto es que es
muy muy difícil porque ahora la
soberanía está sobre la mesa la
presidenta de la comisión europea
enfrenta fricciones y presiones de parte
especialmente de francia para no aceptar
cualquier acuerdo especialmente en pesca
con el reino unido- e internamente
evolution son el primer ministro
enfrenta presiones de su partido y de
los euroescépticos que esperan que
entonces él honre su palabra y el break
si sea definitivamente el break sí pero
los dos quieren llegar a un acuerdo así
que la situación es también compleja
luisa cuáles son las diferencias
principales entre ambas partes
como mencionaba son tres el primero y el
más complejo es el derecho de pesca
aunque representa este el 0.5 por ciento
del pib del reino unido se ha convertido
en la bandera del break sheet en un
asunto absolutamente fundamental la
soberanía de las aguas del reino unido-
las cuotas y la pesca también para
francia como mencionaba también está
sobre la mesa en lo más complejo los
posibles subsidios estatales a la
economía del reino unido y también como
se dirimirán conflictos futuros que no
solamente implica y conviene a boris
johnson sino a los futuros primeros
ministros de este país lo cierto es que
las dos partes han mostrado que quieren
llegar a un acuerdo pero el fantasma de
no lograrlo todavía está rondando tienen
plazo hasta el 26 hasta el 31 de
diciembre para llegar a este acuerdo así
que 26 días en el que habrá marchas
forzadas